we've learned a good bit about the dot
product
the dot product but when i first
introduced it i mentioned that this is
only one type of vector multiplication
and the other type is the cross product
which you're probably familiar with from
your vector calculus course or or from
your physics course the cross
product
but the cross product is actually much
more limited than the dot product it's
useful but it's much more limited the
dot product is defined in any
in in any uh dimension so this is
defined for any two vectors that are in
any two vectors that are in
rn you could take the dot product of
vectors have two components you could
take the dot product of vectors that
have a million components the cross
product is only
only defined
defined
in r
three
and the other i guess major difference
is the dot product and we're going to
see this a second when i define the dot
product for you i haven't defined it yet
the dot product results in a scalar
when you take the dot product of two
vectors you just get a number but when
the cross product you're going to see
that we're going to get another vector
and the vector we're going to get is
actually going to be a vector that's
orthogonal to the two vectors that we're
taking the cross product of
so now that i've i have you uh excited
with anticipation let me define it for
you and you probably already have seen
this once or twice in your mathematical
careers
let's say i have the vector a and it's
only let's have to be in r3 so it only
has three components a1 a2
and a3
and i'm going to cross that with the
vector b
and it has three components
b1
b2
and b3
a cross b
a
cross b
is defined as
a third vector and now this is going to
seem a little bit bizarro and hard to
essentially memorize because this is a
definition but i'll show you how i think
about it when i have my vectors written
in this column form if you watch the
playlist the physics playlist i have a
bunch of videos on the cross product and
i'll show you how to
how i think about the cross product when
i have it in kind of the ijk form but
when i do it when i have it like this
the way you think about it this first
term up here this is going to be another
3 vector or another vector in r3 so it's
going to have one two three terms for
the first term what you do is you ignore
these top two terms of this vector
and then you look at the bottom two and
you say
a2 times b3
minus
a3 times b2 if you've done any of the uh
if you've if and i've made a few videos
on determinants although i haven't
formally done them in kind of this
linear algebra playlist yet but if you
remember kind of cofactor
finding out the cofactor terms for
when you're determining the determinant
or if you're just taking the determinant
for a two by two matrix this might seem
very familiar so this first term right
here is essentially the determinant of
if you if you get rid of this first this
first row out of both of these guys
right here you just take a2 times b3
minus a3 times b2
so it's a 2 times b3
minus
a3
times b2
that was hopefully pretty
straightforward now if not to make your
life any more complicated when you do
the second when you do the middle row
when you do this one right here so you
cross that out and you might want to do
a1 times b3
minus a3 times b1 and that would be
natural because that's what we did up
there but the middle row you do the
opposite you do
the you do a3 times b1 minus a1 times b3
or you can kind of view it as the
negative of of what you would have done
naturally so you would have done a1 b3
minus a3 b1 now we're going to do a3 b1
a3
one
minus a one b three
minus a one b three and that was only
for that middle row and then for the
bottom row we cross that out again or
ignore it and we do a one times b2 just
like we did with the first row a
b2
times a2 b1 or minus a2 b1
a2 b1 and this seems all hard to and it
is hard to remember that's why i kind of
have to get that system in place like i
just talked to you about but this might
seem pretty bizarre and hairy so let me
do a couple of examples with you just so
you get the hang of our definition of
the dot product in r3 so let's say that
i have the vector
let's say i'm crossing the vector
i have the vector 1
minus 7 and 1
and i'm going to cross that
with the vector
4.
so this is going to be equal to a third
vector
this is going to be equal to a third
vector let me get some space to do my
mathematics
so for the first
element in this vector the first
component we just ignore the first
components of these vectors and we say
minus seven times four
minus one times two minus one
times two and these are just regular
multiplication i'm not taking the dot
product these are just regular numbers
then for the middle term we ignore the
middle terms here and then we do the
opposite we do 1 times 5
1 times 5
minus 1 times 4 minus
1 times 4. remember the first you might
have been tempted to do 1 times 4 minus
1 times 5 because that's how we
essentially did it in the first term but
the middle term is the opposite
and then the finally the third term you
ignore the third terms here and you do
it just like the first term you start in
the top left one times two
one times two
minus
minus seven i'll put that in parentheses
minus minus seven times five
and so that is equal to
that is equal to let me see what do we
get
minus seven times four don't make a
careless mistake here that's minus 28
minus two
right minus two so this is minus 30
for that first term this one is five
minus four so it's minus
five minus four
so it's sorry five minus four is just
one
and then two
let's see minus minus thirty-five so two
minus minus thirty-five that's two plus
thirty-five that's 37.
so there you go hopefully you understand
at least the mechanics of the cross
product so the next thing you're saying
well okay i can i can find the cross
product of two things but what is this
good for what does this do for me and
the answer is is that this third vector
right here
depending on whether i stay in the
abstract case or whether i this is the
case with numbers this is orthogonal to
the two vectors that we took the cross
product of
so this vector right here is orthogonal
orthogonal
to
a
and b let me write that
a and
b which is pretty neat
if you just go think about the last
video when we're talking about normal
normal vectors to a plane we can define
a vector by we can define a plane by two
vectors if we define a plane let's say
that i have vector a
right there
and then i have vector
b
and let me do vector b
like this
those define a plane in r3
right let me
define your plane so all the linear
combinations of those two guys that's a
plane in r3
right you can kind of view it as they
they might form a subspace in r3 that
forms a plane
if you take a cross b you get a third
vector that's orthogonal that's
orthogonal to those two
and so a cross b will pop out like this
it'll be orthogonal to both of them
and look like that and so this vector
right there is a
cross b
and you might say sal how did you know
that i mean there's multiple vectors
that are orthogonal obviously the the
length of the vector and i didn't
specify that there but it could pop
straight up like that or why didn't it
you know you just as easily could have
popped straight down like that that also
would be orthogonal to a and b and the
way that a cross b is defined you can
essentially figure out the direction
visually by using what's called the
right hand rule and the way i think
about it is you take your right hand
take your right hand
and let me see if i can draw a suitable
right hand point your index finger in
the direction of a
so if your index finger is in the
direction of a and then i point my
middle finger in the direction of b so
my middle finger in this case is going
to go something like that my middle
finger is going to do something like
that and then my other fingers do
nothing
then my thumb
my thumb
will go in the direction of a cross b
you can see that there my thumb is in
the direction of a cross
b and assuming that you are anatomically
similar to
me then you'll get the same result then
let me draw it all so this is vector
a
vector b
goes in that direction then you know if
you know hopefully you don't have a
thumb hanging down here you know that
your that a cross b in this example will
point up and it's orthogonal to both
and just to make you you know to kind of
satisfy you a little bit that the vector
is definitely orthogonal or that this
thing is definitely orthogonal to both
of these let's just play with it and see
that that definitely is the case and
what is orthogonal what is the what is
our really you know in our context the
definition of orthogonal
orthogonal vectors
orthogonal if a
if a and b
are orthogonal that means that a
dot b
is equal to zero remember the difference
between orthogonal and perpendicular
is that orthogonal also applies to zero
vectors so these could also be zero
vectors notice that i didn't say that
any of these guys up here had to be
non-zero well in a little bit we'll talk
about the angle between vectors and then
you have to assume non-zero but if
you're just taking the cross product
nothing to stop you from taking nothing
no reason why any of these numbers can't
be zero but let me show you
let me show you that a cross b is
definitely orthogonal to both a and b i
think that might be somewhat satisfying
to you
so let me copy
a cross b here
i don't feel like rewriting it
okay
let me paste it
brought a little little other stuff with
it
but let me take that
with let me take the dot product
of that
with just
my vector a which was just a1
a2
a3 so what does the dot product look
like it's that term times that so it's
a1 let me write get some space it's a1
times a2 b3 a2 b3
minus a1 times that minus a1
times a3
b2
and then you have plus this times this
so plus a2 times a3 so plus
a2 times a3 times b1 and then minus
minus a2
a2 a1
b3
and then finally plus i'll just continue
it down here
plus a3
times a1 b2
minus
a3
times a2 b1 all i did is i just took the
cross the dot product of these two
things right i just took each of this
this guy times that was equal to those
two terms that guy times that was equal
to the next two terms equal to those two
terms and then this guy times that was
equal to those two terms and if these
guys are really orthogonal
then this should be equal to zero so
let's see if that's the case so i have
an a1 a2 b3 a positive here and then i'm
subtracting the same thing here right
this is the same thing as a1 a2 b3 but
it's just a minus so that will cancel
out with that
and let's see what else we have we have
a minus a1 a3 b2
well we have a plus a1 a3 b2 there so
these two are going to cancel out and i
think you see where this is going you
have a positive a2 a3
b1 and then you have a negative a2 a3 b1
there so these
will also cancel out
now i just showed you that it's
orthogonal to a let me show you that
it's orthogonal to b
let me get another
version of my
of my
of the cross product of the two vectors
i'll probably scroll down a little bit
and let me go back and let me multiply
that
times the vector
b
b1 b2 and b3 i'll do it here just have
some space so b 1 times this whole thing
right here is
b
a 2
b 3
minus
b 1 times this minus b 1 a 3
b2
let me switch colors and then b2 times
this thing here is going to be
b2 and so it's going to be plus
this is all really one expression i'm
just writing it on multiple lines this
isn't a vector remember when you take
the dot product of two things you get a
scalar quantity so plus b2 times this
thing so b2
a3
b1
minus b2
a1
b3 and then finally
b3 times this so
plus
b3
b3 a1
b2
minus
b3
a2
b1 so if these guys are definitely
orthogonal then this thing needs to
equal zero and let's see if that's the
case we have a b1 a2
b3
so b1 and a b3
so b1 a2 b3 that's a positive one and
then this is a negative one you have a
b3 an a2 and a b1 so that and that
cancel out here you have a
minus b1 a3 b2 so you have a b1 and a b2
you have a minus one it's a minus b1 a3
b2 this is a plus the same thing right
that's just switching the order of the
multiplication but these two are the
same term they're just opposites of each
other so they cancel out and then
finally you have a b2 an a1 and a b3
it's a negative and then you have a
positive version of the same thing so
these two guys cancel out so you see
that this
is also
equal to zero so hopefully you're
satisfied that this vector right here is
definitely orthogonal to both a and b
and that's because that's how it was
designed this is a definition you could
do a little bit of algebra and you could
have you could have without me
explaining this definition to you could
have actually come up with this
definition on your own but obviously
this was kind of designed to have other
interesting properties to it and i'll
cover those in in the next few videos so
hopefully you found that helpful